To continue our discussion on stereotypes, we're going to go back to Dr Markie
Blumer, who you may remember from the motivation and emotions lesson. She's
going to talk about gender stereotypes. Can we talk a little bit about how
women and men may be discriminated against, because of their sexual behavior?
>> Right. So, actually this idea of sort of what we would call maybe gender
stereotypes around sexuality and sexual behavior for both men and women, they
do lead to discrimination. women being people who tend to hold less power in
places pretty much all over the world. that isn't different in terms of sexual
contact so, they've typically had less power. What I mean by that is that
they've had less of a voice. Less freedom around their sexual behaviors,
practices, their beliefs, as well as their dress. Sexual stereotypes and gender
stereotypes actually hurt both people. so, just as women have been confined or
relegated to certain positions in terms of sexual stereotypes and gender
stereotypes. Things like if they dress a certain way then, then they are
expecting to have people, flirt with them or hit on them. Or, or they should
you know, engage in sexual behavior because they're dressed certain way. So,
they are asking for it. Those types of practices are again ways that women's
gender and the expectations men and women have of their gender around sex have,
have harmed them. There's been a lot of discrimination, a lot of pain and
suffering associated with that for women. women enjoying sex have been called
all sorts of names. Women who have more sexual partners than men have also been
called all sorts of names. Really harmful things. Lots of shaming that's taken
place. but if you look at those stereotypes for men, it's also pretty bad. The
differences that they typically have more power in society. So, they aren't
harmed in quite the same way. But there are stereotypes that also do affect
them, things like men should want to have sex. They should want to have sex
with lots of people. if they don't want to do these things, then they're not
really a man, and there's something wrong with them. And they get called all
sorts of names as well, typically names that are pejoratively feminine. so,
again that's denigrating to women and men. but definitely, people of, of
genders, men and women genders, have been harmed by the stereotypes that exist
around sexuality for both of them. And we really all have to work together to
understand that all people regardless of their genitalia and their gender
identification, have the right to be self loving and loving of each other in
sexual manners if they have the freedom a desire to so choose to be.